ان ارادوا. روسيا لالمانيا
دباباتكم ستنتهي قبل دخولها حدود
اوكرانيا. وبعد الدبابات
زيلانسكي يطمع في كرم اوروبا
اكثر ومخزن المانيا الدفاعي يوشك
على النفاذ والسبب روسيا ليتو
امام فوهة مدفع الروس. بينما
يحددون موعد الحرب مع الصين
ويرسلون مبعوثهم الى اسيا
وينشئون قاعدة عسكرية جديدة
للاستعداد. كوريا الشمالية
تعلنها صراحة. نحن مع روسيا
ويجمعنا خندق واحد. والفلسطينيون
يردون على مجزرة جنين والكيان
الاسرائيلي يلطم على خديه معلنا
حالة الطوارئ. وبرج ايفل مسروق
من الجزائر. هذا الناتو يتحضر
لمواجهة روسيا. يوما بعد يوم
تتصاعد الاحداث اكثر والحرب
الروسية الاوكرانية تزداد
اشتعالا والغرب تنزلق قدماه تجاه
حرب عالمية والسبب تدخلاتهم كما
وصفت موسكو. بعد ان شنت القوات
الروسية ضربات صاروخية اكثر من
ست وثلاثين غارة جوية على انحاء
اوكرانيا. ها هو الجيش اوكراني
يعلن حالة التأهب القصوى في عموم
اراضي البلاد ليظهر الرئيس
الاوكراني زينونسكي رافعا سقف
مطالبه بخلاف الدبابات التي تعهد
الحلفاء الغربيون بارسالها قائلا
انه لا يمكن ايقاف العدوان
الروسي الا بالسلاح الكافي.
لتخرج وزارة الدفاع البريطاني
قائلة ان روسيا لم تحقق اي تقدم
جوهري في في اوكرانيا بينما كشفت
الوزارة ان لندن وشركائها
الدوليين سيقدمون اكثر من سبعين
دبابة لكييب. لترد الدفاع
الروسية فورا. مصرحة بان نقل
اسلحة حلف الناتو الى جبهات
اوكرانيا تم تعطيله وذلك جراء
توجيهها ضربات دقيقة لجميع
الاهداف العسكرية. لتجتمع بعدها
دول حلف الناتو وبشكل عاجل.
والهدف هذه المرة طائرات مقاتلة
لاوكرانيا ليؤكد المسؤولون
الغربيون ان المناقشات حول
الطائرات ستكون اكثر شراسة من
الخلافات حول ارسال الدبابات.
بينما تكثف كييف طلباتها لطائرات
اف ستة عشر الامريكية وفق صحيفة
بوليتكو. فهل يغامر الناتو بهذا
السلاح وان كانت النتيجة هي
مواجهة الدب الروسي واشعال حرب
عالمية من جهة تقترب فرنسا
وايطاليا من وضع اللمسات
النهائية على التفاصيل الفنية
لامداد اوكرانيا بمنظومة الدفاع
الجوي السامتي الا ان موعد صدور
القرار النهائي ليس معروفا بعد.
ليعلن المتحدث الروسي بيسكوف
موعد انتهاء الحرب. قائلا ان
بايدن يمكنه استخدام نفوذه
لانهاء الصراع وذلك باعطاء
التعليمات لكييف. لكن بايدن
اختار ضخ السلاح لاوكرانيا بدلا
من ذلك حسب تعبيره. لتعزز بعدها
الخارجية الروسية حديث بيسكوف
معلنة ان حلف الناتو منخرط تماما
في المواجهة مع روسيا التي باتت
تأخذ منحى تصاعديا. ليأتي الحل
من ابي الحلول. الرجل الاصفر
دونالد ترامب يا سادة حيث قال
انه لو كان هو الرئيس لامريكا
لانها الحرب في اربع وعشرين ساعة
محذرا في الوقت نفسه نشوب حرب
نووية على خلفية ارسال الغرب
الدبابات الى اوكرانيا فهل يعي
الغرب تحذيرات ترامب جيدا ومن
الحرب الواقعية الى الحرب
الاعلامية. هنا يسخر الروس من
الدبابات الالمانية قائلين انها
دبابات بدائية وكانها قطط بلا
اسنان مقارنة بدبابات روسيا
ليعلنها الجيش الروسي. سندمر نصف
دبابات قواتنا قبل حتى ان تصل
هذه الدبابات الى ساحة المعركة.
ويبدو ان المانيا دفعت بسلاحها
لاوكرانيا ونسيت نفسها ليعلن
وزير الدفاع الالماني ان الصندوق
الخاص بتحديث الجيش الالماني
بقيمة مائة مليار يورو لا يكفي
وان مخزون الجيش بحاجة الى
التجديد بعد تسليم الاسلحة
والدبابات المقدمة الى اوكرانيا.
المانيا عادت لتغضب وذلك بزلة
لسان من وزيرة الخارجية انالينا
بيربوك والتي قالت انه ينبغي
عليهم ان يتحدوا لانهم في حالة
حرب مع روسيا. الخارجية الفرنسية
ردت سريعا على بيربوك بقولها
لسنا في حالة حرب مع روسيا ولا
احد من شركائنا كذلك. وذلك وفقا
لوكالة الصحافة الفرنسية لترد
المتحدثة باسم الخارجية الروسية
ماريا زاخاروفا قولها انهم
يتحدثون عن حرب مخطط لها مسبقا
ضد روسيا مضيفة لا تقول لاحقا
انكم لن تستمعوا الينا. الصين
كابوس يخنق واشنطن. امريكا ضاقت
ذرعا بالتقدم الصيني والصبر ينفد
لدى الامريكان والحرب تقترب.
ليعلنها جنرال في سلاح الجو
الامريكي في مذكرة داخلية
للبنتاجون قائلا املوا بان نكون
مخطئا. حدسي يخبرني اننا سنقاتل
في عام الفين وخمسة وعشرين.
مضيفا ان الرئيس الصيني شي جين
بينغ لديه في الوقت نفسه فريق
ودافع وفرصة في العام الفين
وخمسة وعشرين. مؤكدا ان
الانتخابات التايوانية لعام
الفين واربعة وعشرين ستمنح
الزعيم الصيني سببا للتحرك وذلك
بحسب وكالة فرانس بريس. هنا
تتحرك امريكا من خلف ستار الظل
لترسل وكيل وزارة الخزانة
الامريكية لشئون الارهاب القيام
بجولة في دول الشرق الاوسط ليحذر
بدوره دول الشرق الاوسط وشركاتها
من فقدان الوصول الى الاسواق
الامريكية بسبب التحركات
الصينية. لتستمر واشنطن
بتحركاتها. ولكن هذه المرة
عسكريا وليس سياسيا لتحتفل
المارينزو الامريكي معلنا افتتاح
قاعدة امريكية جديدة في جزيرة
جوان في المحيط الهادئ. لتذكر
صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال ان هذه
القاعدة ستكون نقطة الانطلاق
الاولى للقوات البرية الامريكية
في حال نشوب نزاع مع الصين بل
ترد بكين على هذه الخطوة كوريا
الشمالية تساند روسيا. توقف غريب
لكوريا الشمالية. لا صواريخ ولا
قذائف ولا تهديد وكانه الهدوء
الذي يسبق العاصفة ليترك كيم
جونغ اون المجال لشقيقته كيم يو
جونغ هو قليلا مع الاوضاع
الخارجية. وها هي تصرح ان روسيا
ستحرق الاسلحة التي تفاخرت بها
واشنطن والغرب عن بكرة ابيها.
لكن المفاجأة جاءت بقول كيمبيو
سنبقى دائما في خندق واحد مع
الجيش والشعب الروسيين الذين
يدافعان عن كرامة وشرف وسيادة
روسيا وامنها. مؤكدة ان الولايات
المتحدة هي المسئول الرئيس
الازمة الاوكرانية وان تحركات
واشنطن تشكل تهديدا لامن روسيا
الاستراتيجي فالحان وقت دخول
المجنون حرب اوكرانيا اسرائيل
تلطم خديها. عندما لم يقم العرب
بدورهم بالوقوف مع اشقائهم في
فلسطين اخذت المقاومة الفلسطينية
زمام الامور فهي لن تنتظر احدا
بعد اليوم. وكما هي العادة تقاتل
وحيدة. وبعد مجزرة جنين خرج
الشاب الفلسطيني خيري علقم ذو
الواحد والعشرين عاما لينفذ
هجوما مسلحا في قلب حي استيطاني
في القدس ويقتل تسعة على الاقل
ويصيب عشرة اخرين. لتصف الشرطة
الاسرائيلية ان هذا الحادث هو
الاعنف منذ سنوات. بينما سقط
خيري شهيدا بحسب سلطات الكيان.
هناك ادانت الخارجية الامريكية
الهجوم مروعة في القدس حسب
قولها. وطالب بايدن فريق الامن
القومي الامريكي بتقديم المساعدة
للاسرائيليين بعد عملية القدس
وفق رويترز? الا تستحون يا
هؤلاء? وماذا عن مجزرة جنين?
اليسوا بشرا? وبعد هذه الاحداث
الكابينة يعقدوا اجتماعا طارئا
بمقر الشباب بدلا عن وزارة
الدفاع لاعتماد نشر وحدات
النخبة? ليخرج لهم الناطق باسم
حركة حماس فان المعركة ضد
الاحتلال مستمرة حتى تحقيق
الحرية والاستقلال مضيفا ان
المقاومة اثبتت ان ردها لن يتأخر
والعدو بدأ يدفع بشكل اولي ثمن
جرائمه. الاحداث والتطورات. بعد
مرور مئة وثلاثة وثلاثين عاما
على تشييد احد اهم المعالم
السياحية في العالم برج عيفيلا
الشهير بالعاصمة باريس. وهي
نفسها مدة احتلال فرنسا للجزائر.
يتداول جزائريون قصة نهب حديد
البرج من بلادهم بفعل اعجاب
المهندس جوستا فايفل بنقبة حديد
الجزائر المستكشف وقتها من فرق
البحث عن المعادن رفقة الجيش
الفرنسي. فليعترف الفرنسيون
بذلك. علماء الذرة يحركون عقارب
ساعة يوم القيامة تسعين ثانية
للتنبؤ بمدى قرب نهاية البشرية
من امر مضحك. اسلحة الغرب تتكثف
في اوكرانيا. وما حذرت منه موسكو
يحدث فهل اقترب الرد الروسي
الحاسم?